[Music]
well welcome to episode two of the addie
hour
on today's conversation we're going to
be jumping in and focusing on topics of
both stress and resilience
and again we're going to have two
different guests from different walks of
life who are going to come in
and talk about their unique perspectives
and some of their overlapping
perspectives as well
so with that i'm really excited to
introduce our two guests today
the first is nba legend alan houston
and allen is the vice president of
player leadership and development for
the new york knicks
he had a stellar 12-year career in the
nba the two-time all-star
and he's also deeply involved in the
community so as a community leader
he's been able to effect change through
his allen houston legacy foundation
and also through fizzle which serves
underserved youth
families and communities nationwide so
want to go ahead and welcome alan
houston to the program thanks so much
for being here
oh thanks for having me i'm looking
forward to this
this fruitful conversation yes
definitely looking forward to it
i'm also thrilled to introduce our
second guest yale professor
dr regita sinha dr sinha is the
foundation's fund professor of
psychiatry
and of neuroscience and of child study
at the yale school of medicine
she's the founding director of the yale
stress center
and she's also an expert and a
researcher who looks at the biological
processes in the brain that underlie
stress and those processes and how
they're linked to some of the unhealthy
behaviors associated with stress
including things like addiction at times
she's a sought-after
expert and contributor on multiple media
platforms
and she's also conducted workshops on
stress management and self-care
so really thrilled to welcome dr sinha
to the program today thanks so much for
being here
thank you for having me it's my pleasure
so i think this is going to be a very
timely conversation in a lot of ways
just based on where we are as a society
right now
but i also imagine that the topics we'll
be discussing will extend
far beyond what we're thinking about
today and are just important life
principles as well
so i'm really really excited to be able
to to walk through some of these
conversations and to hear
about your experiences and some of your
tips for our audience
listeners as well but before we get into
some of that did want to set the stage a
little bit and just see how both of you
are doing in the midst of everything
that's going on
i mean i can say honestly for myself
there is an element of tiredness that i
feel
um in this moment some of that i know
we're just coming off of the anniversary
the one year anniversary from when much
of the country went into lockdown
in some ways it seems it's hard to
believe that it's been a year already
in some ways it's been slow in some ways
it's been fast
but then also with everything that we're
still fighting and dealing with around
the racial injustices
really trying to fight against the
systemic and underlying racism that's
really embedded in our country
even with some of the news about the
trial that's coming forth for
the former police officer uh chavin in
the the case of george floyd's murder
all the emotions surrounding that all
the tensions that we have with our
political system and some of the
some of the challenges and and frankly
ugliness associated with that which we
really emphasize in episode one
i know for me as i talk to family
members and friends
as i interact with my students as i talk
to people in the community
as i talk to people in faith communities
and church communities just really kind
of this element of tiredness and really
wanting to be able to move through
and move forward even though there's
still work we have to do
so i know there's a lot there but i'm
just curious how both of you are really
managing
everything right now from what we're
dealing with in society and even in your
personal lives
um so alan if you'd be willing to uh to
jump in i know
that's not a light question by any means
but important yeah but
no but it's a real question it's it's
where we are as we
kind of talked before we hopped on live
i think everybody is understanding we're
in a world that we hadn't seen before
um so we're all trying to navigate it
uh you know for me
we are approaching the a year since kind
of lockdown and i remember literally
uh march 10 of last year was the day it
really kind of hit me because i was with
our team with the knicks and
they they literally stopped games
this on march 10th and so
you know i'm just kind of going back to
saying first of all i can't believe it's
been a year
for one and then it's like what was i
doing at the beginning
uh i think for me i have been had such a
busy lifestyle it gave me a chance to
spend time at home reflect um so i kind
of had this dual perspective one
was like i was really
kind of relieved that i could just have
have a real reason to be home and not
be anywhere else and engage with my
family
but on the other side you see the pain
that so many are going through uh and
the pain that you're kind of sensing
that you don't know how to kind of deal
with and navigate
um because i feel like as a nation
uh some layers finally got peeled back
right
it was really kind of it's almost like
we're kind of getting to the root
and discovery of who we really are and
not who we're portraying to be
as a as a nation and didn't look pretty
you know and so we're trying to figure
out okay it's almost like
living in a house with a brother or
sister that you're still
trying to learn and know and you're
finding out some ugliness but you're
still
family so how do we you know how we
navigate that
and push through it deal with the ups
and downs which i love this conversation
of stress and resilience
because it's not just the physical
tiredness it's the emotional it's it's
knowing that i have to endure this you
know and i just have to
um so on one side it's like i know i
have to keep pushing
i have no choice but on the other side
it's like why do we have to keep
going over this again you know and
uh so i i call myself an eternal
optimist you know but
i i just have always felt like you know
um
my perspective is eternity you know i
know god that has a as
ultimate plan and a destination so i try
to keep that in mind
and try to work myself back but when you
get
to re you know where you are it's it's a
struggle
right it's a fight because not everybody
has the best intentions and
and different experiences so
uh it's always a challenge but at the
end of the day
i just try to remind myself of why i'm
here
you know um and that's not always to be
comfortable
i was to make a difference yeah yeah
that
that
higher purpose in a lot of ways um and
so many you know the part they really
one of the things that really resonated
with me is just the idea of in a sense
like it was a blessing in disguise to be
able to
have to deal with these things but that
doesn't make it easy by any means
yeah like you said it's it's things that
were already there that we have to
address head on
but there's almost no escape because not
i mean
i mean there is always a way to escape
but when it's right there in front of
your face
these are the realities then yeah but i
think i think the thing about escaping
like it seems like this conversation is
about escaping is not really escaping
but escaping is is is not really dealing
with it
so you're not really escaping very true
yeah yeah i think sometimes people think
they are and it's it still comes back
like you said vegeta what about you
in this in this moment you know i
uh a lot of what alan was saying i was
resonating with
i can't believe it's been a year uh it
feels like it's gone
by and it's both fast and slow at the
same time
there were aspects that i appreciated um
having moments to think about things
without feeling rushed
um cutting out all travel which was a
blessing
but but you know it also really
uncovered a lot of who we are
challenged us in ways we didn't know um
you know how we would react as both as a
community
uh as a nation but uh you know just in
myself
uh too you know we were challenged in
different ways um
and so i think it's been hard from that
perspective
you know you have you have to relearn
some things
of how to do you know how to function in
a very restrictive environment
your social network is not there for you
in a way that in the same way so you
sort of have to
find a new way of sort of connecting
with people
and that's a more conscientious way of
putting oneself
out which you can't take things for
granted um
you know and and then from a work
perspective it got very
stressed because there was lots of sort
of restrictions
and um there were worries about how
would we get things done that we have to
get things
that you know get done and then taking
care of the people around
me my family you know personally it was
hard
for family members who one couldn't see
who were ill and sick
you know so there's that whole dimension
of it as well
um but you know it's been
it's been tough for so so much more
tough for other people
um who have lost loved ones i had
illness in the family but not not
actually lost uh
somebody and so that you know i feel a a
level of gratitude
uh for for what um
you know what i could sort of manage and
and
even though one was one was challenged
in different ways
yeah yeah in several ways it sounds like
you're talking about just the mixture of
emotions that come
to the loss and then some of the
resilience in the midst of the stress
and
i really like how you brought out the
learning piece as well because i think
that's been
key in a lot of ways and some of that
has just been
having a willingness to learn i would
say too yeah and with learning there's
always
there are always mistakes mean i'm sure
allen you could talk about that from a
sports standpoint where you did from a
life standpoint but really
being willing to learn and have those
mistakes happen i know for me with my
students a lot of it has been talking
about
basically resetting goals saying okay
these are the goals i have in mind
this is a pandemic i can't actually meet
those goals i need to kind of reset
and set new goals and then i still can't
meet those goals so i reset so i mean
it's really a cyclical
iterative process and not being so hard
on ourselves that we don't give
ourselves that room to learn because as
you both mentioned this is
completely new for all of us i mean
unless any of us were alive 100 years
ago we haven't experienced this
before so there's no template for how to
go through it
but we do have principles which we can
apply as well and so i think that's
going to be a really rich part of this
conversation
as well and so i mean i know you both
already have had passion about
these aspects of stress and resilience
and so anything you'd like to share just
in terms of how you've applied that
passion
over the last year in this pandemic and
how
other things that you've had to shift
even in the framework for how you've
approached some of these things
yeah no i i think uh you know the
challenge
uh really got you to think about um
[Music]
you you know one's own sort of sanity
first
obviously at your own personal level uh
an acceptance of what we don't know
um because i remember having this
conversation with with
colleagues about whether this is an
acute trauma that we're facing and
for i just said um i was on the other
side of it and felt and continue to feel
that this is it wasn't an acute trauma
like you have a disaster
you know a hurricane and and of course
you deal with the
consequences of the hurricane but the
hurricane leaves
this is chronic relentless
and not knowing at least back in march
in april and may
and through the fall not knowing when it
would end if it would end
in a way that would be even
at all salvageable as we come out of it
and then
all other layers which i know ni you
referred to in your first episode and
and we may talk about it but there were
other things that got uh you know the
onions that have pulled back
as alan you were referring to who we are
in different ways
and challenging that also came about so
i think just
for me personally there was a lot of
acceptance and focusing and staying with
the acceptance
and staying with the multiple emotions
that come up
um i appreciated having time to exercise
more for example to have control over
your your schedule in a way that uh you
could you could do those so there were
some nuggets of
of uh good i suppose in one's own
sort of existence but it came with a lot
of these other
uh mixtures so
yeah yeah i'm curious about one piece
you brought up too before you pivot back
to alan but just this idea of it not
being an acute
stressor but something that was much
more chronic
how does that how do our brains respond
to that and what's the what's the impact
on that
on us as individuals like how should we
be thinking about
the nature of the stressor itself and
how we approach things yeah
that's it's a great question and it
really gets to the heart of sort of what
is stress
and and and how do we how do we
um conceptualize it and then study it
and then deal with it
um you know acute stressors are things
that have a beginning and an end
very discreet and and um
and they challenge us and it can be
controllable or uncontrollable of course
and uncontrollable really challenge us
in ways that um
that can probe and risk
or very quick action to save us and and
that kind of thing and
but then there's a recovery from it
and there is a coming down of of
our physiologic as well as our mental
processes sort of
um you know whether it's relief whether
it's sort of a sense of accomplishment
whether it's learning as you've
pointed to learning is a big part of it
adapt adapting to the situation
sort of putting it together to know it
like i'm not gonna do that again or i'm
not gonna feel that or
and sometimes making you know growing
from it sort of making decisions like i
think we're going to
do this differently the next time so you
have room to manage that
sometimes sometimes uncontrollable
stress can be ones that
really challenge you in ways that um
you know put you on the spot to to learn
in
major ways and you have to be open for
that this
the chronic relentless is one that
unfortunately a number of people in our
community already know what that is
not in the way of the pandemic but there
is a lot of chronic relentless
stress um you know if you were about to
get evicted for example or you don't
know where the next
uh paycheck is going to come or whether
you will have the rent money um
you you know not just like one example
of it
but this had those qualities you know
your own person may not be okay you
might you might get affected by this
illness
or somebody you love might be you might
lose someone who is already sick
uh there's just a lot of uncertainty
in there um and like i said there wasn't
a clear
message about how this was going to come
how we were going to come out of it
so any any ways in which socially we
could get
to sort of gaining control those things
weren't happening in a very
concise way some states were better than
others and we can we don't have to get
into the social side of it but
just generally thinking about a stressor
it was a chronic
relentless uncontrollable stress
for a long time yeah that's very very
true
and alan you you hinted at this as well
but how have you
been trying to address that both in your
own life and
in the communities that you're involved
in mostly just
doing this just talking you know just
listening to people
you know i think anytime you go through
some
something i think traumatic
if i think being in a support group
being able to express and listen to
connect with people who are going
through something similar
that's what i found a lot of strength
and and
recovery and just connection with and
you know obviously
technology allowed that to happen uh
some you know you kind of get
zoom fatigue uh but for the most part
um i felt like
as much energy that got drained from us
we could we actually i felt like i got
energy from certain conversations you
know
sometimes you know you get on prayer
calls with people and
you know just just talking even though
like
people are immobilized and they're
sitting in the same physical situation
or same
physical place um you can kind of be
moved
you know in a different way by having a
conversation with someone
connecting with someone uh just being
there to listen
uh to people so i think that's one of
the things that
we've been doing with um kind of our
support groups mentoring you know
leadership development
uh just really uh listening to a lot of
young people
um letting them voice their concerns
letting them voice what they uh their
aspirations
um you know just getting their feedback
on what's going on in their world and
how they interpret
and perceive things that are going on
socially
and i think a lot of people haven't felt
like they had a voice
and they hadn't been validated so
i think that was the primary way for me
um kind of in a in a macro sense to just
deal with you know the stress of
everything
um connecting with people and and
you know within myself you know doing
the same thing you know
reflecting a lot um
just thinking about what's most
important in life
most important relationships uh and just
trying to keep it on that
on that plane yeah that's so important i
think this the element of community that
you brought up just really giving people
the space
to stay engaged in community and like
you said re-centering too
just through centering in terms of the
strength that we can build from
community and re-centering spiritually
i think as well strength that we can
have from god in those moments as well
one piece that i was curious about from
both of you based on what you've just
said is just if you've seen
specific strengths emerge that weren't
necessarily
as evident before as people have gone
through
this chronic stress
i i think the what did the the positive
or the strength of this
what what happened was is related to
what alan is saying which is that it
forced us to think about community in
some
in many ways you know what people have
been busy in their life or doing the
things that they need to do or
or struggling and and managing things
and haven't had a chance
to take a step back or reflect and this
forced us to do that
in tough situations as well as in
situations where uh
you didn't know what to do um you
it allowed us to dig into that sense of
sort of reaching out
supporting one another um using zoom
you've heard a lot of that using zoom or
phones or whatever other technology
or just even connecting with your you
know church groups or
whoever even you're just the neighbors
not that you were seeing them but
but in the you know watching them and
then connecting
you know through through some media um
modality it really allowed you to sort
of
get get into that uh connectivity
issue that we that is so important for
humans
you know we tend to be social we are
social animals and it was really a good
way to
to hone into that but for a lot of
people and a lot of young people
they really um you know connect but they
miss
the other piece the contact and you hear
that from them
um you know and so actually a lot of
reassurance and
and sort of teaching of patients which
is harder
um you know so i think even that got
challenged well that is a strength it's
perhaps something that we didn't you
know we weren't aware of how much
investment we need to make in that
and i think we got to we got a chance to
see this
you know the community not community
fabric not being as strong as it could
have been
yeah that's really true i've had lots of
uh yelling conversations with neighbors
across the street that just didn't exist
in a different way but it's funny
because you can you can see that
that uh tension and that desire too
you know as people are out doing yard
work and they're getting closer together
and all of a sudden it's like oh i
forgot we have to social distance it's
like that yearning it was just starting
to
to bubble up so yeah i think you're
exactly right he's teaching us
a lot yeah i mean i think it definitely
gave us a a better appreciation for just
you know nature you know just you know
doing the things that
are just natural to us just walking
talking
exercising you know those things that
just help us be whole um i think that
what got strengthened
um is is i think vegeta kind of said it
it's like just our ability to think
and reflect just our ability to to think
about things to
to really think about them more deeply
right and
and it gave us a little bit more of a
self-awareness like again that we
didn't like what we needed to know right
within ourselves
or just other people i know okay that's
what they're really thinking
you know now i see what they're really
thinking i thought it
but now i can see it they said it and we
we're talking about it
and we're being forced to talk about
uncomfortable
things and and in things that i didn't
know were not okay to say
and um so those things i think helped us
uh in a lot of ways um now we gotta you
know apply it
you know and just continue to be mindful
of those things
um but yeah i just i agree i think those
things
it did help just the idea of thinking
and i think you made a great point too
as well because i
i have seven children so i see the
progression of an eight-year-old all the
way up to a 21
year old and you know you realize that
the older you are the more you're okay
with
kind of dialogue and thinking and that
type of engagement with the younger you
are
i just want some physical engagement you
know what i mean so
you really see this natural
progression of how how we live and how
we develop
and how we really do need young people
the younger we are
to have some social engagement it's it's
this is extremely important um
and that's why you know i'm praying that
everything can quicken
you know so that people can kind of just
get out again and feel that sense
yeah that's so important regia do you
have suggestions for people in terms of
that piece that allen just brought out
especially for you you mentioned
young people like still trying to have
those spaces of uh
a physical connection that's so
important
well the physical connection is is tough
right because you have to at some point
make the contact
um but but i i think
zoom goes a long way i think people
seeing using their different
uh sensory modalities to connect with
other people
i think there's creative ways in which
teachers and others have
have reached out to do that
you know i've heard for example uh
getting kids together for
uh joint movement things you know
whether it's joint
dance workshops or singing together and
and
yoga together and some physical activity
in that way
um has gone on which has been important
and the kids have enjoyed it and again
you know depending on the age group i
think that uh
that matters um i do think that
that the other piece of this and maybe
you were going to get to it is that
the need for connection around the
difficulties that have gone on this past
year as well
and because i think the children
particularly how you connect on that
is really important um but there has
been such
a tremendous amount of loss in many ways
even though we are talking about you
know we got challenged and we tried to
figure out how to cope with it and
and managed to to strengthen those other
those aspects
there was a sense of loss you lost your
way of of living
and your way of being and at the most
you know just at the top level and then
there was lost in very physical ways uh
family members losing i mean loss of
just multiple
levels and the pain related to that and
i i feel like we don't talk enough about
that
because we spend so much time wanting to
be you know as americans we like to be
upbeat and happy and and and oh we're
all great and resilient
um and and
not perhaps paying as much attention to
what's coming apart
yeah yeah that's really important so i'm
curious how do you
suggest for both of you that we deal
with that loss in terms of
even just acknowledging that it's there
but then having the tools to move
through it and to build resilience
because i think in some ways sometimes
there's there are misconceptions about
what resilience
really is and what it isn't
so how what would you say to people in
terms of what are appropriate
ways to address those things and what
things should we be trying to avoid
in terms of how we approach it yeah
i mean i'll just start i i think what
alan said is really important i think
the support and listening and talking
is one of our very natural tools
but really going to where the dark side
is
you know where the darker aspects of it
not be afraid of that
to reach out about pain and sadness and
about
distress um and to stay with it because
uh we want to go very quickly to
how do you cope with that and what do
you do with it and that there's a
natural way in which that can
there's a risk to promote avoidance in
in that way
and so i i think the the unjust
knowing pain there's a lot of beautiful
historical
context of you know you know if you know
pain it gives you the answers
it shows you what what path you need to
take
and so pain and distress teaches us as
well
and i my own personal belief is
and what i see around is that we don't
we don't pay as much attention to it so
there's a risk
that people who are facing the loss in
that very deep way
tend to put it aside not talk about it
because others are not paying as much
attention to it
and have moved on from it um and so we
do a lot of work around our on that the
trauma of things
um you know um and
how to accentuate it so that in fact not
to have people
suffer but to know their pain there's a
difference in those
in those aspects that's really important
that's really good i mean that blessed
me you know right there
you know because i i'll be honest with
you i didn't really have a good answer
but
you know when you know dr vegeta talked
about
embracing not you know embracing the
pain in a way that you know that you can
get through it you can recover
um you know often when when a player
gets injured in sports for example
um i i kind of go back to
when i had surgery a few times and it's
painful
uh going through that process the
healing the recovery but
oftentimes you come back smarter wiser
you know you learn from it
and the other thing that i like what you
said like is about
you know don't run it don't run from
pain you know
it's it's almost like you know we know a
lot of people who you know may have
have an injury or ailment and you're
like i'm okay i'm good i'm good well
that that's that's one thing between
playing tough but then another thing and
being smart
right and if you ignore that pain which
i think is given to us
to it's hey there's something going on
here
you know it should be something you pay
attention to
you know you don't dwell on it sit in it
think about it but you you
you do something about it you notice it
and then you recover and when you do
you start to understand that this pain
actually helped me and i can
i can always recover i think that's the
one thing that i i always think about is
you know when when a person gets injured
on in sports you
you know that you know especially
nowadays with the
medical um advancements
you know you you're going to recover and
you're going to be back
playing again you know it's it's um
so i think that's the thing that i look
at is from an emotional standpoint is
you know i don't want to be paralyzed by
anything
you know i i want to know that
i can overcome things as hard as they
may
be um you know whether something has
happened in
you know your relationships your
marriage you know family
um things that may have happened like
you just have to think okay i'm gonna
get through it i'm gonna it's gonna
i'm gonna bounce back and the pain is
something that i'm
gonna navigate through i often say to a
lot of a lot of people too like
sometimes
there's nothing to do but to go through
it
you know alan that's so true and yet
we spend a lot of time trying to not go
through things
in you know in in the way that um and in
fact there are social sort of norms
about that
um and it's unfortunate because there is
uh you know socially and culturally
we've had so much pain that has gone
around
losing a son losing both parents i mean
if we just stop for a moment
and think about what that is how is the
person who is feeling that
experiencing it we might start to
connect with each other we might go back
to that built-in coping that we have
which has to do with connection
in a way that we start to understand
each other differently
you know i just you made me think of
something too and i appreciate this that
sometimes the pain we place the pain in
the wrong
i shouldn't say in the wrong place but
like when something happens to us let's
just say your family member
you know god forbid gets killed or you
know a lot of our young people
you know there's violence and so we
we know that we're going to get through
it but we hold on to the we we keep
holding on to why it happened right we
hold on to the person that
that made that decision to take a life
or
and we it's almost like we give them
the license to keep us in pain
right or and and that's hard i know it's
tough but
you know the pain if we uh
dwell on why it happened
who made it happen i don't that becomes
unhealthy in itself and i think that's
where i think
faith comes in is right look you know we
have to learn to
not dwell on why it happened uh who made
it happen
but the fact that we can get through it
and how do we get through it
you know stay with that
right no that's important i agree with
you
and unfortunately because we are we are
so wired to sort of say well we're going
to be
you know i can't look weak in
facing this that is another big um
social
construct out there um and you take it
in your stride and if you don't then you
are somehow
not not your lesser than we have a lot
of
things out there that get people out of
pain perhaps in the moment or they think
they get them out of pain and it just
creates more
more difficulties um later on and so
that
that's um that's made things complicated
yeah silva said that ties back even to
what al i know you mentioned the
beginning about the
the escape and whether that's really
escape or not so i think regia you're
bringing bring that up
reena up as well um just to even bring
it home a little bit more
practically for a lot of what we're
going to be going through i think in the
months ahead
i did want to ask both of you in this
aspect of what you're talking about how
to deal with the pain and process it
you know what things they're they're
coming online with the shop and trial
and things like that
all the emotions that will bring to the
surface again
with george floyd's murder are there
practical
pieces of advice that you have for
people in terms of how
to process that from a biological
perspective from a stress perspective
from a spiritual perspective
and a lot of the themes we've talked
about i think can be applied but it'd be
great just to hear both of you elaborate
on
exactly how people should be thinking
about that coming going forward
yeah i'll say two things come to mind
the first is i think
in a parallel way george floyd's
you know heinous uh murder was may 25th
it was early
in our you know early in this whole
covet piece and a lot of what has gone
on in
during covid unfortunately the way
people have been dealing with suffering
and pain has been
you know we've seen increases in alcohol
use increases in other kinds of
behaviors
that you know pain use uh
use of pain prescription pills and other
things and a lot of that is just people
trying to cope
and figure out what to do uh right and
so here we are again in this moment
where um some things are gonna come
come out a lot of things are gonna come
out you're going to also get reminded
flashbacks of not just the episode and
what happened after that but
everything else that got uncovered
ugliness or
not so ugly things that god said um
really not
connecting with each other as a
community evidence of that and yet some
other
in other ways as a community we people
did rise up and say
no we're not going to take that there
was evidence that was
put in people's faces that you had to
face that
um i i think really you start by
noticing what is coming up for you you
know you start by really becoming
uh becoming aware of your
pain and the emotions that are coming up
and what else it reminds you of
and um sitting with it and communicating
that to others
connecting with others building more
commun community around it i think can
be very important at this time
and really trans then sort of taking
that on and saying where do you
you know what do we want this to lead to
um because that you know as part of sort
of facing things we don't give this as
much attention but
we as humans really want agency and so
giving a getting a giving agency in a
way that is
um adaptive and um
you know solves some things or begins to
help us get through it as alan says you
know what is going to help us get
through it
uh that'll that'll come up if we go
ahead and and process it and stay with
it
that's excellent excellent i i
personally don't have a whole lot of
high expectations honestly you know
for for uh the trial i think
i'm trying to avoid being too consumed
with it i want to be aware of it
i want to be aware of what happens and
how it affects people and
again let it continue to spark dialogue
healthy dialogue
and understanding um
you know where we this has put this
whole thing has put us on a really
constant
search for real truth right because i
feel like in society with people
i don't even think people know what to
even trust anymore
you know and so
i think you just gotta keep searching
for truth right and in
in the in the bible the bible talks
about
you know when pontius pilate asked jesus
what is truth what is it
you know it's not it's a difference
between information and facts and
and truth so like in this case like this
whether chauvin or
whatever i think you just got to look at
look at real motive real intent of the
heart
um you know i we we've done something
that we're doing we're talking with uh
our foundation we're meeting with
um police officers and seeing how their
uh sensitivity training goes seeing how
how what goes into your department's
development in these areas just
ask ask your police department you know
what what are you guys doing in the area
of developing
kind of training is going in so you can
kind of learn i think as community
leaders
we should be aware of our local law
enforcement practices
to train um officers
and so we can just keep drawing those
connections so
you know as vegeta said what do we want
to look moving forward we have to
develop more trust
between young people law enforcement
authority and i'll just kind of end with
this thought
my friend is is writing a book in the
name of he's done a lot of youth
development work and his book is called
why youth don't give a damn anymore
that's the name of his book you know
first i'm like why you want to make that
but at the end of the day
um young people are looking for models
you know they're looking for people who
really model what they expect
and if we don't give them that then how
can we expect them to
show us respect and show authority
respect for authority
um so i think we you know
it kind of went off a little bit but i
think i look at i look at
you know the whole trial we just
we can't we we're going to look at so
many
cracks you know in in in this case
but at the end of the day like my
grandfather used to tell me like you
know right from wrong
make sure you're doing right and make
sure you're holding other people
accountable
in your circle you know for doing the
same
that's so good and one theme that seems
to jump out to me from what you both
said is just a theme of understanding
both in terms of understanding ourselves
when we feel whatever emotions rising up
in response to things and then
understanding others and really building
those community bridges as well i think
is going to be really important
but the one last question i have for
both of you just with everything that
we've talked through that's been so
important
i think it's it's important and great
that we're
diving into these tough issues because a
lot of times these things kind of get
left
under the surface as you both mentioned
but i also love to hear what gives you
hope in this moment
for really being able to think forward
and think ahead
for me my faith you know god god
um i just
have always uh relied on it
uh in my relationship it's seen me
through in the past
um and i think that that's
you know it's like in basketball right
you you lose a game you miss a shot
something happens you get her hurt you
just
you you go back again you get another
opportunity
and you believe that you're going to
make the next shot you believe that all
the
work you put in and all the preparation
you've put in
is going to prepare you for the next
time and
you know i believe that there's only one
loss in the season that's the last one
every other every other one is just a
learning experience right
the one loss is the one that you're
seizing right
so you know i kind of look at
you know i believe my ultimate coach is
god and he's going to continue to put me
in the best situations
not every situation is going to be
comfortable may not lose might not win
every game
but it's always developing me growing me
you know advancing me
um and i'll just start with that
perspective and i think what it helps me
do
is we've talked a lot about pushing
through right we
talked a lot about um
stress and recovery right the the the
energy
that goes up and in the recovery that
you need to
kind of come back quickly um so it gives
me hope is that
i i use my faith to see the other side
of it
right to see the the other side of
what's about to happen
you know i think that's that's how i
define faith you believe in something
that's going to happen it hasn't
happened yet you don't see yet
in front of you and so
i think that's what gives me hope i
think um
when i think about relationships they
deep down
people think they want to have a
connection
they want to have a deeper connection
you know and understand themselves
but they haven't learned they haven't
been in a situation or an environment
that's allowed them to do it you know so
a lot of times we get caught in
why is this person you know mean and
nasty and evil and all that
well you got to think about where where
their soil
you know where the weather roots are
where they've come from what they've
been through
then you kind of think okay uh
i think that's the way i kind of try to
look at people look at life so i try to
see the
good side see how i can
you know be the part of the solution and
part of the other side of it
um so like during this whole time
i kept thinking about vision like i i
kept thinking about like
use this time to really sharpen your
vision
since you can't go anywhere you can't do
much use it to envision what you want to
do when you can
you know and really train that side and
that part of and that's kind of where i
still
have been thinking about so doing that
when you start thinking about what's
possible what you can do what you want
to do
it it helps a little bit more hope
you know come in instead of looking at
what's going on now and what happened
you kind of look forward so i think
that's that's kind of
um something that i've tried to make
intentional
that's so good in so many aspects of
perspective too which i know we've
talked about
in other situations before but just that
perspective on on the big picture
that god given perspective that this
this isn't the end that there's more to
come and
like you said just perspective on
learning where others are coming from to
what they've gone through um and having
that project
and i just think and i'm sorry i just
say this i just believe
through like i really believe that's a
choice
a lot of people you guys know more than
me like there are some imbalances and
constructs constructs that people have
internally with their
uh genetic makeup um and what's going on
but i do think that deep down
we have to look at it at our capacity as
a choice like we have a choice to look
at it that way and believe that
and we have to use that choice yeah i
would just
i would add you know i i see alan's
perspective fully
um of what he's saying is so important
um
i i think the hope uh for me
is coming from the young people too
they they are they're not happy
they are very upset with what is going
on
just generally one had to say not
everybody of course
but they are they have forced us to
engage
in a way um that i had not seen
before um and that gives me hope
that they they have basically you know
whether it is
school shootings whether it is shoot
violence that we are seeing you know
racial
ones whether it's um you know structural
racism
and uh you know or or
microaggressions or um you know
how covetous response was you know all
of those pieces how it's affecting them
you know they're voicing their pain but
they're also challenging us
and um at a very basic level
you know and and they're expecting more
and so i think there's there's uh hope
in that
because they're they're really looking
they've gone
approaching life and approaching what's
happening in the world
in a different way than when we were
younger um
but also i think forcing us to see their
pain
which makes uh certainly motivates me to
say
this is not okay we've got to do better
and it it
sort of appeals to our hopefully to our
own
better angels to sort of come up with
solutions to break down barriers if we
can to
sort of think outside the box to
not get stuck in the choices as alan was
saying to sort of
think of alternate things and alternate
choices and
other ways of of other alternate
perspectives as you said me
um and so those because it's amazing how
if that can be
there are lots of different ways you
just have to open your mind up to it
um and uh we are faced with really lots
of
lots of challenges but the hope is is is
there and we have to believe in it
because we want we want to
we have to find a better place in a
better way yeah
that's so true and it ties together what
you're both saying both about the choice
and perspective and the choice in action
i think in a lot of ways the youth are
really paving the way
and showing us that choice in action i
think in some ways it's up to us to even
um
step up and step step with them in those
pieces
exactly yeah joint join them
and it gets back to that community too i
feel like we just went full circle
so that's yeah that's a great way to tie
things together
well again i'm deeply appreciative to
both of you for jumping on the podcast
for or jumping into this conversation i
think there's so many
rich pieces that that are going to be
important for us i know even for me
i'm sure i'll be listening to this again
there's always you know even as i'm
hosting there's always nuggets that i
pull out
a second time through so i know that's
definitely going to be the case here as
well so thanks again
both to alan dr sinha for joining on the
addie hour i know this is going to bless
a lot of folks and be informative and
empowering as well
definitely appreciate both of you thank
you dr saha so it's a pleasure
you know learning from you uh visiting
with you and thank you neet
thanks for uh inviting me of course
of course thank you nee thanks for
having me alan it was a real pleasure
for to to chat with you and with both of
you and
i look forward to hearing more of the
adi hour yeah
you